problématique il est problématique se
moque pas mal d'élèves ne voit pas très
bien ce qu'il veut dire et quelque part
ils ont raison pourquoi parler de
problématique de la dissertation quand
on peut parler de problèmes
[Musique]
eh bien il ya une petite nuance sur le
plan du langage le nom féminin pour les
matic et évidemment dérivé du nom
masculin problèmes et sur le plan des
idées il ya une petite différence
le mot problématique ajoute une
précision par rapport aux mots problème
la multidimensionnalité autrement dit
par les deux problématiques plutôt que
de problèmes
ces présupposés que le problème
intellectuel de la dissertation et
complexe au point qu'il faille
l'envisager sous divers angles le sens
précis du mot problématique repose donc
sur l'opposition entre les problèmes
simples d'une part et les problèmes
complexes
d'autre part par exemple savoir si un
billet d'avion et cher est un problème
simple il suffit de nous comparer les
prix pendant 5 minutes sur internet pour
se faire une idée
en revanche savoir si le loisir rend
l'homme heureux est un problème complexe
au sens où il est impossible de donner
rapidement une réponse tranchée
la plupart des problèmes de philosophie
d'histoire d'économie etc sont montés
problèmes complexes trouver la
problématique d'une dissertation s'est
donc trouvé le problème intellectuel
complexe qu'il faut résoudre ce qui est
une étape cruciale de la méthode de
dissertation d'ailleurs si vous
souhaitez connaître ma méthode de
dissertation j'ai un cours gratuit de
méthodologique vous explique tout de a à
z avec des schémas et des exemples vous
pouvez vous aussi recevoir mon cours
gratuits de méthodologie de la
dissertation souhaite en cliquant sur le
lien qui s'affiche en haut à droite soit
en utilisant celui qui est dans la
description de cette vidéo
inscrivez-vous et vous m'en direz des
nouvelles dans cette vidéo je vais vous
expliquer comment trouver logiquement la
problématique d'une dissertation c'est à
dire sans avoir besoin d'être inspiré ou
de connaître son cours par coeur
regardez bien jusqu'au bout et vous
pourrez appliquer ma technique en trois
étapes
dès votre prochaine dissertation
[Musique]
quand on réfléchit pour résoudre un
problème on part toujours de quelque
part puis l'on déduit d'autres idées de
notre idée de départ
c'est un peu comme en maths ou les
exercices nous donne des hypothèses de
départ imaginons par exemple que je
doive organisé un voyage au japon selon
le point de départ de la réflexion le
problème ne sera pas le même
si je pars sur un coup de tête la
semaine prochaine le problème c'est
comment toutes organisées le plus
rapidement possible mais sans se ruiner
mais si je suis passionné par la culture
japonaise et si je veux en faire
l'expérience de le pays même là mon
problème et où ali et quoi voir au japon
pour en tirer la meilleure expérience
culturelle
autre hypothèse encore si je pars en
vacances après une période de travail
intense là mon problème est comment
découvrir le japon en se reposant le
plus possible je n'ai pas imaginé 50
situation différente vous m'avez compris
le point de départ de la réflexion
permet de définir précisément le
problème que vous souhaitiez organisé un
voyage au japon où trouver la
problématique d'une dissertation la
mécanique et la même vous devez
identifier l'idée qui permet de cibler
très précisément le problème
intellectuel que vous avez à résoudre en
dissertation le point de départ de la
réflexion c'est l'aspect le plus
frappant du sujet c'est une idée simple
et évidente qui est dans l'énoncé vous
lisez l'énoncé est quelque chose vous
étonne
vous vous dites que quelque chose ne
colle pas et ça vous turlupine votre
pensée rencontre un obstacle
il y a un problème et c'est bien normal
en dissertation parce que la plupart de
les énoncer sont justement faits pour
réveiller le doute
les profs les conçoivent dans cette
optique bien sûr c'est plus facile avec
certains énoncés qu'avec d'autres
et comme pour beaucoup de choses dans la
vie il n'y a pas de recette miracle
vous devez vous entraîner pour exercer
votre jugement plus vous traiter de
sujets de dissertation meilleur vous
serez pour trouver logiquement la
problématique maintenant en voyant
comment s'y prendre en pratique avec un
exemple je prends un sujet de
philosophie parce que ce sont les plus
difficiles à problématiser si les fps
apprendre à mourir
quel est selon vous l'idée frappante
dans ce sujet mettez la vidéo en pause
et prenez quelques minutes pour
réfléchir c'est bon
alors on fait comme si ce qui est
frappant quand on lit ce sujet c'est
l'évocation de la mort déjà la mort
c'est un peu tabou dans notre société
mais surtout le mordin est aussi pas
spontanément la mort et la philosophie
à notre époque on considère la
philosophie comme une discipline
littéraire surtout une matière du bac et
les philosophes sont des intellectuels
qui écrivent des livres compliqué dont
la mort n'est pas le thème principal
bref l'hypothèse proposée par l'énoncé
philosopher égale apprendre à mourir
cette hypothèse doit évidemment nous
étonner allez semble à première vue
aberrante
c'est donc ça le point de départ de
notre réflexion la mort est peut-être un
thème de la réflexion philosophique mais
réduire l'activité de la philosophie à
l'apprentissage de la mort c'est une
hypothèse qui paraît radical c'est
d'ailleurs pour ça que j'utilise le
verbe réduire une autre manière de
l'expliquer c'est de constater qu'on a
du mal à répondre oui à la question
fille les hauts faits et ça prendra
mourir parce que celle disqualifierait
beaucoup de questionnements
philosophiques
par exemple la métaphysique qu'on peut
définir comme l'étude d'un ordre de
réalité supérieure et bien la
métaphysique c'est une partie importante
de la philosophie qui ne se réduit pas à
la préparation à la mort l'hypothèse
proposée par l'énoncé semble donc très
réductrice
c'est de cette première idée qu'on va
dire le problème intellectuel à résoudre
dans la dissertation
[Musique]
normalement cette deuxième étape entre
guillemets n'est vraiment pas difficile
si je veux partir au japon dans trois
jours et bien j'en ai dit que je dois
préférer les solutions les plus rapides
pour organiser mon voyage
d'ailleurs je suis prêt à payer un peu
plus cher pour ça en dissertation le
point de départ de la réflexion engendre
souvent le même type de problème par
exemple est-ce qu'un préjugé et
pertinents est ce qu'une contradiction
est bien réelle est ce qu une
exagération apparente peut être
justifiée est ce qu un présupposé et
pertinents et il y en a encore d'autres
vous les découvrirez en vous entraînant
à traiter des sujets aux pannes ont
maintenant mon exemple philosopher s
apprendre à mourir mon point de départ
c'est que l'hypothèse proposée par ce
sujet semble radicales comme ça on se
dit que la philisophie ce n'est pas
uniquement apprendre à mourir
du coup quel est le problème
intellectuel qui en découlent mettez la
vidéo en pause pour réfléchir quelques
instants bon ce n'est pas très difficile
là le problème c'est de vérifier si
l'hypothèse est vraiment aberrante
est-ce que ça n'a aucun sens de réduire
la philosophie à l'apprentissage de la
mort ou bien est-ce qu'il faut creuser
l'hypothèse bien sûr on fait un peu
semblant dans la problématisation parce
que le but de la dissertation c'est
justement de creuser l'hypothèse qui
paraît aberrante de prime abord donc à
ce stade j'ai trouvé le problème
intellectuel à résoudre dans la
dissertation
c'est à dire que j'ai l'idée de la
problématique il me reste encore à la
formule
[Musique]
j'ai donné beaucoup de cours de
méthodologie de la dissertation les
milliers d'heures depuis une dizaine
d'années et du coup c'est par
l'expérience en faisant des retours à
des élèves encore région des copies que
j'ai découvert la plupart des principes
de ma méthode concernant la formulation
de la problématique c'est toujours le
même souvenir précis qui me revient à
l'esprit
1 les élèves m'avait transmis la
correction donné par son prof un plan
détaillé de philosophie la problématique
les grandes parties et les arguments
étaient des phrases à ralonges
bourré de vocabulaire philosophique
technique je me souviens que j'étais
gêné parce que je n'arrivais pas à
comprendre la problématique fallait que
je relise la phrase que j'essaie de
comprendre ces différentes parties
séparément en les prenant une par une
bon au bout d'une minute j'ai fini par
comprendre ce que son prof voulait dire
et alors j'ai dit à mon élève c'est bien
que votre prof vous donne une correction
mais tu as compris et il m'a répondu non
pas vraiment alors c'est sûr que quand
on lit une problématique comme sa très
longue bourré de vocabulaire
philosophique
ça dégage beaucoup d'autorité
intellectuelle encore plus quand on sait
que c'est l'oeuvre d'un prof agrégé
mais que va-t-il se passer si c'est la
phrase d'un élève et qui est l'élu à 200
à l'heure par un correcteur qui veut se
faire une idée de la qualité de la
dissertation le plus vite possible
eh bien ça va lui prendre la tête et il
va probablement sac et la copie or ça il
ne faut pas que ça arrive
que faut-il faire du coup pour bien
formulé la problématique de la
dissertation
il faut miser sur la clarté c'est déjà
important parce que cela va faciliter la
lecture et la compréhension du
correcteur mais c'est aussi important
pour vous parce qu'il est plus facile de
construire le plan détaillé avec une
problématique clair ah oui parce que la
problématique c'est le problème
intellectuel de la dissertation et le
plan détaillé ce sont les éléments de
réponse si le problème est clair les
solutions le seront probablement aussi
alors comment faire pour rédiger une
problématique clé pour faire simple je
vous conseille de suivre deux règles
tout d'abord privilégier les phrases
courtes parce que plus une phrase est
longue plus elle risque de perdre le
lecteur essayer plus précisément de vous
limiter à un seul verbe conjugué seconde
règle
bannissez le jargon c'est à dire les
termes techniques que vous n'êtes pas
certain de maîtriser notamment en
philosophie en économie et bannissez
plus généralement tous les termes que
vous n'êtes pas capables d'utiliser
dans une conversation le principe
derrière ces deux règles c'est que vous
ne devez pas compliquer la problématique
pour impressionner le correcteur
n'arriverait pas impressionné de toute
manière votre copine on a rien à faire
il reste encore deux choses à savoir
pour bien formulé la problématique de la
dissertation
la première c'est qu'elle doit être une
question fermée c'est à dire qu'elle
impose un choix parmi des réponses
préétabli par exemple quel est le
rapport de la philosophie et la mort est
une question ouverte parce qu'elle ne
cadre pas les réponses possibles
cette question favorise ce que les profs
appelle l'effet catalogue c'est à dire
l'empilement d'éléments de réponse sans
articulation logique avec une question
fermée on ne peut répondre que oui non
ou bien une nuance entre les deux et les
réponses alternatives possibles pousse à
articuler logiquement les éléments de
réponse dans le plan détaille la
dernière chose à savoir pour formuler la
problématique c'est une convention vous
connaissez peut-être déjà la
problématique doit être différente de
l'énoncé du coup si le problème
intellectuel et transparent dans
l'énoncé eh bien il faut le reformuler
ça ne sert pas forcément un grand chose
mais c'est comme ça maintenant que je
vous ai expliqué les principes pour
formuler la problématique de la
dissertation
voyons ce que ça donne avec mon exemple
le sujet philosopher c'est apprendre à
mourir
je vous rappelle que le point de départ
de la réflexion c'est que l'hypothèse
philosopher égale apprendre à mourir
semble a priori aberrante et je vous
rappelle que le problème qui en découle
c'est de savoir si cette première
impression est pertinente
est-ce que ça n'a aucun sens de réduire
la philosophie à l'apprentissage de
l'amour ou bien est-ce qu'il faut
creuser l'hypothèse voici comment j'ai
formulé la problématique de ce sujet de
dissertation la philosophie peut-elle se
réduit à la préparation à la mort alors
vérifions qu'elle a bien les qualités
requises
elle est bien courte est clair il n'y a
aucun terme technique
s'il ya une question fermée et enfin
elle est différente de la question de
l'énoncé sur le fond on retrouve grosso
modo l'hypothèse proposée par le sujet
mais avec la nuance du point de départ
de ma réflexion
on comprend bien en lisant ma
problématique grâce au verbe réduire on
comprend bien que l'hypothèse me paraît
de prime abord aberrante
voilà j'ai trouvé et formuler la
problématique de mon sujet je vous
propose maintenant d'essayer à votre
tour dans les commentaires choisissez un
sujet de dissertation et appliqué
précisément
ma méthode avec ses trois étapes pour
trouver logiquement la problématique
je vous dirai ce que j'en pense pour
réussir les autres étapes de la
dissertation à n'est pas seulement la
problématisation je vous invite à vous
inscrire pour recevoir gratuitement mon
cours de méthodologie soit en cliquant
sur le lien qui s'affiche en haut à
droite soit sur celui qui est dans la
description de cette vidéo si vous avez
des questions sur la problématique de la
dissertation n'hésitez pas à me les
poser dans les commentaires et j'y
répondrai sans faute
je suis romain je suis toujours avec mon
fidèle aristote et vous étiez sur mini
de culture générale appelée vous n'avez
pas besoin de vous prendre la tête pour
trouver logiquement la problématique de
la dissertation
[Musique]
à